we begin in Egypt where the cop 27
climate Summit has been extended another
day organizers hope the new deadline
will give negotiators time to find
common ground on several thorny issues
now one is compensation for countries
hit by climate disasters but there could
be movement on that after a surprise
offer from the European Union linking
financial aid to tougher emissions Cuts
vulnerable Nations have already made it
clear that an agreement would be
impossible without funding for loss and
damages
you take for instance
um some of our countries like in I think
in Dominica there have been debts in
Antigua they have been that's as a
result of allocate
so we are consider this an urgent matter
that should be addressed and we will not
back away from a minimum position at
this cup
that a loss and damaged fund be
established in order to make available
in extra Financial Resources to pay for
the recovery of our Islands
well I'd like to speak now to Johanna
flashbart state Secretary in the German
Federal Ministry for economic
cooperation and development he's in
charm al-shek Egypt I would like to
welcome you first to DW and thank you so
much for taking the time to speak with
us we know there are a worrying number
of issues are still left to be resolved
at this Summit um perhaps biggest of all
is financing what is your position on
richer Nations compensating poor
countries who are suffering the effects
of climate change
I mean it's absolutely essential for us
to help those in need those affected
most uh by the ongoing climate change
these are usually countries that have
not done a lot for this climate change
those emissions are very very low and
therefore we supported those countries
of vulnerable countries how we call them
here to get this an agenda item but
Germany also organized something
practical on the ground we organize we
launch the global Shield against climate
risk so to have a double track one on
the negotiation side but the other one
bringing immediate help to those in
needs and so can you give us a peek
behind the scenes there in charmele
Sheikh and tell us what is the hold up
on coming to a deal on financing
well the question here at the
negotiations first of all to start it
that was done two weeks ago and the
other one is how to design the health
and there were several options on the
table to create a fund under existing
entities like the green climate fund or
to some to do something Standalone
something brand new and the European
Union as well as many other old
industrialized or donor countries
were heading for looking at a number of
options but as we saw that our people
our partners in the developing World
specifically the most vulnerable were
not satisfied with looking at the whole
range of options Yesterday by Executive
Vice President Timber month announced
that Europe is open to decide on a fund
here in chamel Sheikh already given that
all those who are part of the problem
are also part of the solution so we need
to extend the so-called donor basis and
involve countries like China to get the
problem solved so we know that Europe is
willing to pay for climate losses and
damages in poorer countries but there
are some rich Nations who say they don't
agree with this approach they believe
sending it would send money to countries
that are not on the front line of crime
of climate change can you tell me more
specifically who we are talking about
here specifically
well I think it's basically here now or
about the design of the different
instruments and whether or not we get a
dedicated fund uh and to Pace into this
fund and we believe that this has a has
to be a broad range of countries also
Innovative instruments but to be very
clear and explicit countries like China
have to be part of those who are paying
to those who are in need and we also
want to link this with the overall
mitigation agenda because we need to
limit climate change to 1.5 degrees
otherwise we need more efforts for
adaptation and at the end there is more
pain in the world and more need for to
pay for loss and damage okay so it's a
bringing it's about are in part bringing
China on site I would also however like
to talk about Germany's role in climate
change specifically we know that
scientists working on the climate action
tracker have a rated Germany's policies
as insufficient to meet the Paris
agreements 1.5 Celsius temperature limit
I think poorer countries will look at
that and wonder why they should do their
bit how would you respond to that
the different Institute but I need to
say Germany is still one of the very few
countries who have a very clear Target
to be climate neutral not only 2050 but
also already 2045 It Is by law it's not
not just a political announcement yes we
are in a difficult situation at the
moment
due to the Russian war of aggression
against Ukraine we need to use a little
bit more coal during this winter season
and maybe the next one we will need a
bit more gas from other countries
because we don't want to buy the gas any
longer from Russia but this doesn't mean
at all that we are not following our
line on the contrary the cold phase out
will be speed up from 2035 to 2038
already to 2030 so all our friends can
believe we will exhaust ourselves to be
Pioneers on climate change as well thank
you very much for that that's Johan
state Secretary in the German Federal
Ministry
Ministry operation development really
appreciate your time